people saying things like well okay
everything you're saying is nice for
like a eurocentric world everything
you're saying is nice for like an
american-centric world but what about
people in the far east or what about
people in australia right so this is one
of the one of the critiques i saw on our
uh groundhog day video oh all the stuff
you're saying about there being more
light in the world you know you know on
the vernal equinox for instance
other stuff you're saying about there
being more light in the world
uh that doesn't apply
if you live in australia so
checkmate jonathan pedro
[Laughter]
to this i just have to say
australia is upside down world people
like people are walking around upside
down in australia there are yeah it's
the antiquities
there are insane hybrid animals
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Applause]
so hello everybody we are back uh for
universal history with richard rowland i
am super excited about the next few
episodes because we are going to be
talking about the far east about mongols
about president john about all
what people consider to be all these
crazy medieval legends but we're really
going to dive in
and we're going to make sense of it and
and see how it can help us understand
something about how the world works and
so richard take us just take go for it
let's do this so as jonathan and i we're
just discussing there's too much stuff
like there's so many details and there's
so much information
uh that this is gonna be a slow build so
everyone buckle in this my plan for this
episode uh that we just and
our plan that we just discussed is that
we're gonna lay a foundation uh looking
at somebody basically you could say like
the or texts for
how the christian world and how the
roman world thought about the far east
and engaged with it although sometimes
also the other way around
uh and then we're gonna go from there
we're gonna build from there um and just
very lightly tease
the presser john stuff which is the
really fun juicy stuff um and that's
going to be uh next this is your next
episode so today who knows how many of
these are going to take but yeah we're
going to we're going to do this it's
going to be a lot of fun yeah this is
really cool stuff so i thought that we
would start by addressing i was i
actually i do read the comments on our
youtube videos i know that you're not
supposed to do that but i i do it you
know and uh one of the common uh things
that i've seen the last couple of videos
um is is people saying things like well
okay
everything you're saying is nice for
like a eurocentric world everything
you're saying is nice for like an
american-centric world but what about
people in the far east or what about
people in australia right so this is one
of the one of the critiques i saw on our
uh groundhog day video which has like
been weirdly popular um i mean it's not
weird it was a lot of fun to do but one
of the critiques on there i saw is oh
all the stuff you're saying about there
being more light in the world you know
you know on the vernal equinox for
instance
other stuff you're saying about there
being more light in the world
that doesn't apply
if you live in australia so
checkmate jonathan pedro
um
to this i just have to say
uh australia is upside down world people
like people are walking around upside
down in australia there are
yes the antiquities it's the activities
there are insane hybrid animals and
people
like i
i was thinking about this because
recently i got to hang out with a friend
uh a friend of a friend who was passing
through dallas from australia um and and
he lives in australia and and he's a a
pretty interesting dude and so we were
just we we had a meet-up and i just had
all kinds of questions for him about
living in australia and what's that like
and
things and the thing that i came away
with was man that's the other side of
the world like australia is a weird
place uh sounds like an awesome place
we'd love to visit this is nothing
against australia i know we have some
australian listeners but australia is
the other side of the world um and most
importantly it's the other side of the
world from jerusalem
so
this is the thing that i want to kind of
start out by pointing out is that the
christian
uh
grammar
right um i i joked to somebody the other
day that this supposed to be a universal
history series but like low-key it's
actually a universal grammar series
where grammar meaning the old in the old
sentence means something like
the way everything connects and relates
um to each other and what the proper
names for things are things like this
i want to say a little thing about
australia because yeah it's important to
understand
let's say people will think what you
said is weird but
when you understand the idea the ancient
idea that people you know on the south
south pole or in the southern part of
the world we're upside down of course we
we think of it in a very simplistic way
but we can understand it in a in a
little more subtle way which is they are
upside down in the in the heavenly
patterns they're upside down
they encounter the the pattern of the
lights in the heaven and
they are also like you said they have
all these creatures i mean if they were
ever dog-headed men kangaroos are like
good candidates
for that
because look just think of what they
look like and so
and and there's a way in which when the
europeans will encounter australia the
way it will happen will be related to
the upside down when we say that
australia was a colony of criminals you
know that there's this whole fringe
aspect of australia which is which can
it can help you understand why the world
lays itself out this way if you think
about it and the way we're trying to
help you understand it yeah and if you
think about i mean it's easy to read
some of these things uh that we'll be
quoting from today um there's a there's
a great anglo-saxon text that i'm not
going to read from today but it's worth
your time to look it up and read it it's
called the wonders of the east and it's
basically just a catalog of here are all
the weird hybrid creatures that you're
going to encounter when you go out to be
on the edge of civilization
and like some of those things sound uh
oh well clearly he's describing a
rhinoceros or something like that here
but some of those things are just like
super weird you know but also like
if if you know the history of european
colonization exploration of australia
they when they would send animals back
they'd shoot an animal and and kill it
and ship it back to england and they'd
get it at the you know
they'd get it at the the academy in
england and they open it up and dissect
it and start looking for the seams on
the duckbill platypus because obviously
this is a hoax this animal couldn't
possibly exist in real life right so
australia is actually a great example of
what we're talking about it's not a it's
not
it doesn't disprove the categories that
we're using here it actually kind of
demonstrates australia is a really real
way in which
uh in which hybridity and the culture of
the edge
and the upside-down world all that stuff
manifests itself and none of that means
australia is bad
and also none of it
none of it implies the fact that there
isn't an inner experience of let's say
right aboriginals like these things are
but we cannot we can only formulate the
world from the perspective in which we
live and so the idea that we are
formulating this universal perspective
but the universal perspective from the
point of view of our own story of our
own interactions doesn't invalidate the
existence
the or the inner possibility of
aboriginals to have their own story and
their own
way to fit into the universal history
but we don't have
access to that we have access to our
story and and the best way to encounter
even
something which to us would be as
strange as let's say australian
aboriginals is to be able to
to fully embody our own story and to
counter them in the proper way right so
the um
that is a super underrated point that
you just made there like i feel like we
almost need to spend some time talking
about that later or something like that
that's the thing like if if you want to
most honestly
interact with someone else
another culture another world
you have to honestly and legitimately
and authentically embody the world and
the story that you actually belong in
so because one of the a simple example
that is biological is that when you
encounter the strange there is a danger
of infection and you can't
you can't pretend that that doesn't
exist because because europeans weren't
careful about the way that they
encountered the strange massive
populations were wiped out because of of
not understanding that you were
encountering things that don't fit with
your identity and if you're not careful
those there can really be a a
destruction which is not which of course
there was the war and
and and all that kind of stuff but even
just in terms of disease right it
actually could create that that type of
interaction so think about how we talk
about extraterrestrials for example and
people who are all excited about
supposedly encountering extraterrestrial
life but they don't un if they don't
think about it properly in terms of a
medieval way of thinking
then that encounter if it could ever
happen could completely annihilate us
even
without the ill or goodwill of of either
parties right
yeah so
the the medieval account of the world
is
jerusalem-centric um and this is how i
want to kind of frame
the way we talk about this going forward
i'm not saying in in all of the series
you shouldn't be coming away from this
and hearing oh richard and jonathan are
just a couple of white guys with their
american-centric
point of view about the world and things
like this like i i acknowledge i live on
the edge i live in the land of the
barbarians right i live in the extreme
west right all the things that that
means and that it embodies right for
good and for evil that's the world that
i live in but the medieval account of
the world is jerusalem-centric so they
would put
um they would put jerusalem at the
center of the map um
i have a funny story about this uh
there's a there was an american seminary
that i walked into evangelical seminary
once
and um
this particular seminary very you know
had a really big focus on overseas
missions and things like this so in the
lobby of their building their main
building there's a massive uh like
mosaic on the floor uh it's a map of the
world and all the different places that
this denomination has sent missionaries
to and things like this but the
headquarters of the denomination where
you were
was the center of the of that map of the
world like
laid out in terms of the floors like
we're the center we're sending things
out and i remember remarking to a friend
at the time it's like you know if this
was the middle ages jerusalem would be
in the center we'd be way
over here on the edge right
and that's the account of the world that
we're trying to to help people
understand and so when we talk about
engagement with the the far east we're
really talking about the way that the
middle east engage with the far east
which then colors the understanding of
all of the sort of jerusalem's children
right the the christian and the roman
world
during the christian era
so um that's where we're going to be
doing and what i want to do in this
video is just basically lay down a
little groundwork for vocabulary and
perception and then we can get into the
really fun juicy bits in the in the next
video so
the or text for kind of unders or the ur
texts rather for understanding middle
eastern and therefore european
engagement with the far east
is the legends of alexander the great
and i'm going to say legends broadly
because there are a lot of first-hand
accounts from alexander and his generals
and then there are other accounts that
proliferated
well on into the middle ages
for example probably about the 6th or
7th century a letter began to circulate
called the letter of alexander to
aristotle and uh
there's a greek original which is lost
but it was definitely written in greek
originally that that version was lost
but there's a latin version that that
survived and that latin version was
translated
other times and for instance there's an
anglo-saxon like an old english
translation of the latin which is
actually this is a case of the
translation is better than the original
um because the anglo-saxon version has a
much more satisfying ending um that's
really dwelling on alexander's mortality
in kind of this melancholy way that the
aimless accent is really good at
um so that's worth reading um and it's
really actually
that whole thing becomes quite important
to the legends of prestor john which
we'll talk about later right so for
people who don't know most people will
know this but for people who don't know
aristotle was alexander's teacher so
there is a
relationship between aristotle and
alexander the great and there has been
speculation all through
the history to re to understand what to
what extent aristotle's metaphysics and
aristotle's vision had an influence on
alexander's imperialism and you know how
it is it that they continue to
communicate and so these letters pop out
as kind of legendary manners in which to
explore that question yeah and so
plutarch for example in plutarch uh in
his lives he has uh the life of
alexander the great
and um one of the most important things
that comes up about in the life of
alexander the great as he makes it to
india which of course he did do
historically
um is uh that he encounters what a greek
are called the gymnosofas
uh in other words the uh or gymnos the
naked philosophers
that he encounters on the banks of the
indus river and you can go and read
about this if people are curious there
are
literally dozens of real you know
historical groups in in india
that are identified as the gymnosofas
because the basic idea of a naked
ascetic is like
happens all over the world right
certainly happens all over the east
um
and there's a story about uh how
alexander captures 10 10 of these uh
naked philosophers because they've been
stirring up trouble for him
and he says i'll let you guys go
if you can answer some riddles
which is this isn't plutarch's lives uh
and this is great
um and uh i'll give you just a couple of
examples of the riddles uh first one he
asks uh he says
who is more numerous the living or the
dead
you know like are there more dead people
or more alive people
and uh the falafel philosopher says that
the living are more numerous because the
death no longer exists right which is
like a nice
and that that itself is a nice uh kind
of riff on or play on the kind of the
contrasting um contrasting ideas in the
ancient world between like the greek
world the semitic world about death and
existence and things like this um
the second being asked whether the earth
or the sea produced larger animals said
that the earth did because the sea is
but a part of the earth so like all
these all these riddles you know are
like a little clever you know
and um and in the end he he lets them
all go with with presents with gifts
and um and so this is one of the but
it's it's kind of the first recorded
encounter
of
the of western civilization
with eastern philosophy and uh it's it's
a pretty neat little encounter
and
ancient and medieval encounters with the
far east other than the the
career of alexander ancient and medieval
encounters with the far east
are geographically usually limited to
trade routes
which for the roman empire usually means
the trade routes of what at the time was
called the at the time of crisis was
called the erythrian sea
and the era 3 and c was the name for
the what what nowadays we would call the
red sea plus the persian gulf plus the
indian ocean and that was all understood
as like a single maritime trade area
um and so silk from china for instance
would have to pass over a really long
overland trade route and then it would
take a turn towards the south uh it
would go to india and then it would sail
across this era three and see until it
comes to ethiopia and by the way this is
why we talked about back under like our
very first videos on ethiopia
ancient sources often conflate or
combine ethiopia and india right even
though ethiopia is sort of the extreme
south and india is the extreme east
because anything coming into the roman
empire from india would have to pass
through ethiopia at least that was the
case for a very long time
uh but there are other examples uh for
instance uh flores who's a roman
historian he records chinese and indian
ambassadors actually coming to bring
gifts to caesar augustus like this so
this is at the time of christ
and i want to read a little bit of what
he says because it is
um it's quite lovely actually he says
thus even scythians and sarmatians sent
envoys to seek the friendship of rome
nay the series that's the chinese came
likewise and the indians who dwelt
beneath the vertical sun
bringing presence of precious stones and
pearls and elephants
but thinking all of less moment than the
vastness of the journey which they had
undertaken
and which they said had occupied four
years
in truth it needed but to look at their
complexion to see that they were people
of another world than ours
now this is not a it's not like a racist
thing or something like that but it's
just to say
the romans when they in cave encounter
with these ambassadors of the far east
who'd come to bring them these gifts
they noticed the difference they you
guys are from another place
yeah yeah
and so in in all of this literature we
basically see the far east presented to
us as a land of extremes right so it's a
world of naked aesthetics on the one
hand
but then also like you could say like
unbound potential
in the form of luxury goods
um and i don't know uh it might be
useful sometime
jonathan if you're just out of video
ideas uh to do uh to do something like
on the symbolism of luxury goods and
like the symbolism of decadence right
yeah
um
uh because it's it always seems like the
the failure to properly orient luxury
goods towards you know a hierarchy say
like a crown or a throne an altar at
church
um that results in decadence um and the
way that the romans experienced this is
that the wealth of the east and even the
kind of near-east so in the case of like
persian emperors this was experienced by
romans as being extremely decadent so
one of the things diocletian does for
instance
is that he basically
there's there's there are ways in which
diocletian is the first true emperor of
rome
right in in the sense that diocletian is
the guy who basically says sorry you
can't approach me
directly
right and he surrounds himself in kind
of the mystery and the hierarchy and the
distance
um nowadays when we use the word
byzantine to describe bureaucracy in
like a negative sense right diocletian
is the one who invents that
and he does it in kind of imitation of
the great persian kings of kings yeah
and that that whole structure uh was
very effective for running the empire at
that particular point in time
and of course it gets carried into the
byzantine era but at the early stage
when the romans encountered that when
they saw their own people start to do it
they saw that as ways that the east was
the decadence of the east you could say
was like corrupting you know
you know
homespun roman virtue yeah but you can
see it you can understand it as the east
itself that is the sense in which
light comes from the east but there's
also a sense in which there's something
like uh un
un
unchecked glory is a way to understand
that and that is what accounts for the
decadence of hierarchy because that's
one of the things that hierarchy offers
it offers a kind of pride and and that
kind of danger right so you can
understand why both of those the idea of
the naked aesthetics of these
rigorous spiritual beings that exist you
know in the east but then also this
other extreme which is something like
the dark the dark side of light not the
dark side of light but like the the
dangerous side of of light and of
hierarchy i mean it's just i mean you
can just think about sunlight right if i
stand in the sun
you know too long without protection
especially at certain parts of the world
right i'm going to get burned you can't
get burned right that's it that's it's
that easy right yeah um
so there are a number of kind of
important texts in the christian
tradition uh which helped bring
this symbolic experience of the far east
into the four obviously there are a lot
of biblical texts um and the biblical
attack uh texts that are really
important to our purposes are
a lot of the ones that discuss ethiopia
as being an example of the extreme the
edge
and i'm not going to cover those again
because crp cr previous works yeah um
but there are also these texts that talk
about
gog and magog um and and uh the the
enemy like coming down out of the north
yeah um and we're gonna talk a whole lot
more about that in the next video so i'm
going to maybe just bracket that for the
moment
but it's important to understand that
people
ancient maps are oriented yeah
it's super important to understand that
so you have the sentence where jerusalem
is at the center we are facing east
towards the sunrise and then on our left
is the north and on our right is the
south and so these these relationships
are so important in terms of also how we
experience light you go on the left hand
we have the dark place you know we have
the light coming from the east and so
all of these things will be important in
understanding the way in which for
example we understand the barbarian
hordes coming down and this idea of this
dark power that comes from the north is
important we have to understand it that
way yeah and there's something to be
said for
um the way that uh
cultural memory can sort of bear a scar
um
to give to give like an opposite example
sort of um would be
um in uh
for the scandinavian peoples who were
themselves some of those barbarians
coming down out of the north and you
know wrecking rome and all this other
stuff right but for the scandinavian
people is the invasion of the huns in
the sixth and seventh century there's
the invasion of the huns that
that basically just like burns a deep
scar in their cultural memory right and
so for a scandinav for scandinavian and
like western european
storytelling
the bad guys come out of the east
right the invader comes out of the east
and actually this is going on this is
still going on in tolkien right where
tolkien is like here's like a germanic
mythical pre-history that's what tolkien
kind of starts setting up to do and so
for tolkien you know sauron is in the
east the the hordes the barbarian hordes
things like that
they're in the east and it's it's the
civilization is just like these tiny
little outposts on the western coast of
the world right which is very much how
the northern european people saw
themselves where they had the huns
coming in out of the east and uh
wrecking them really badly and they're
just kind of like holding out over here
not just the huns obviously the mongols
also come out of the east and actually
wreck up a good bit of eastern europe um
and actually the kind of thing that
keeps the huns and moguls from like
coming all the way west is probably just
the weather
at some point uh uh
the composite bows made by step nomads
uh start to fall apart in really humid
weather yeah and so um so it's probably
probably the humidity of like western
north northwestern europe that that kind
of saved them but
anyway uh in a in the same kind of a way
here um if you're living in the levant
uh there are dangers to the they're
drained dangers directly to the east um
usually in the form of the parthians the
persians
who
were never seen as
the same kind of barbarian their the
parthians the persians were like uh
an equally developed civilization right
but but also rome's main rivals in that
area but to the north and kind of the
northwest
that's where you have the scythians are
coming from there that's where you have
the
you know all these what are essentially
celtic tribes that are invading and then
later a few centuries later it's the
germanic tribes that are invading from
the north right um gog and magog um
which
which uh we'll talk about more um in the
next video all that stuff is to the
north and of course the north is where
alexander goes and
builds his gates right to keep gog and
magog out
yeah so
um some other texts that are really
important for understanding the
symbolism of the far east um herodotus's
histories
which is
probably we could eventually if we
wanted to do like a whole video on the
histories or maybe somebody should do
like a video series on the histories
that would be maybe a fun symbolic world
discussion group to do actually i'll
think about that um
because herodotus is histories is the
first example of kind of a universal
history it was like an attempt to take
here's everything we know about the
world
and put it together in one place and so
it's really important to this project
that we're doing now
um and uh
by the time at the time that herodotus
writes the histories the greeks slash
persians are not really aware of the
geography of india or of asia in general
east of the indus basin and so herodotus
says that india is the end of the
habitable world he says as far as india
asia is inhabited land but thereafter
all of the east is desolation nor can
anyone say what kind of land is there
um
but uh but he he also talks about he
also talks about indians living
far away from the persians southwest
he's talking about the indian
subcontinent uh and we're no who are no
subjects of king darius um
and in uh some of some of his books for
instance in book three of the history
herodotus gives an account of some of
the peoples of india who'd been
encountered by greek traders and by the
persians
and he talks about them as being very
diverse
makes reference to their eating habits
some of them eat raw fish others eat raw
meat others practice vegetarianism
and talks about all this different gives
really elaborate descriptions of them
not just descriptions of them but of the
animals that live in that part of the
world for instance
there is uh in this part of india that's
that that the sandy desert lies here in
this desert they live amid the sand
great ants in size somewhat less than
dogs but bigger than foxes
i don't know what he's talking about but
this vision of like the giant ants out
in the desert um is in almost every
medieval description of the east after
this so that that that image like of
giant ants
stuck in somebody's mind for sure at
first it shows up in that anglo-saxon
text i was talking about the the symbols
of the uh the wonders of the east where
you have the great ants out in the
desert digging up gold you know and and
talking about how the the men like scare
the ants off and come collect the gold
and things like this
um
herodotus mentions uh he mentions um
um
the indian tribe of the khalitiyai for
instance who the reason they get a
mention is because they have the
practice of what is sometimes called
funerary cannibalism
uh great name for a metal band funerary
cannibalism or or sometimes it's called
endocannibalism basically it's the idea
of of eating your deceased ancestors
yeah um which is
something that was horrifying to the
greeks and herodotus actually has like
this weirdly almost like anachronistic
moment of like
cultural
relativity or something like that he's
like well we think this is terrible but
they think it's terrible that we burn
our ancestors so
you know
um yeah so uh there's there's a bunch
more stuff about the far east and
herodotus is histories um but then the
the texts that are really really
important to us for this series um we're
going to come back to
this text that we've talked about before
on the show the apocalypse of
pseudomethodius this is a
it's essentially a uh
syrian work of universal history that is
written at a really important time a
moment in time which is when the the
arab caliphates were really
wrecking christianity in the near east
and um and so he's trying to kind of
address that and kind of answer some
questions about why is that happening
and how are the how are they going to be
judged for what they've done to the
people of god
and uh which is very common theme in
apocalyptic literature
and in this we very at the very
beginning we get this this idea this
idea that the far east is populated by
philosopher kings who are descended from
a fourth son of noah and so i'll just
read this it says in the 620th year of
the life of noah in the 20th year of the
third millennium after noah left the ark
the sons of noah established a new
settlement in the outer earth
so kind of out on the edge towards the
east and name that place famine uh which
is syriac word for eight after the name
of the number of the eight souls who
left the ark in the hundredth year of
the third millennium a son was born to
noah in his likeness and he named him
yonatos or like uh
gyunton
in and syrian
in the 300th year of the third
millennium noah gave gifts to yonatos
his son and sent him into the land of
the dawn so he sent him farther east the
tower of babel happens and it says then
that the onus was the son of noah went
to the east as far as the sea and the
place called the country of the sun
where the rising of the sun takes place
and he settled there this yonatos
received from god the gift of wisdom and
he was the first to discover the
practice of astronomy
nimrod the giant came down to him and
was instructed and took from him the
council by which he ruled this nimrod
was of the heroes of the children of
shem and he was the first to rule as a
king on the earth and in the 799th year
of the third millennium in the third
year of the reign of nimrod he pontipos
the king of the sons of ham sent strong
and able men from the sons of japheth
wise in regard to all aspects of
craftsmanship and architecture and they
went down to the land of the dawn to
jonathos the son of noah and built a
city for him and called it yonatos after
his name and i read all that because
it's to understand the idea of universal
history in general especially from the
syrian point of view
it's really important to understand that
each of the sons of noah have kind of
their own unique symbolism associated
with them
right so you've got the sons of shem who
are the basically the mesopotamians
right the fertile crescent the
mesopotamians these are your city
builders this is
civilization and you could say it's the
closest to being something like the
center right
um then you've got the sons of japheth
who are basically europeans
right and these are craftsmen
and they kind of in this account they
kind of represent something like techni
yeah in the service of civilization
right
and then you have the sons of ham and
the sons of ham are in this
particular story they are
uh africans specifically in in this
passage they're specifically egyptians
yeah right but it's uh but but as
africans slash egyptians as traitors and
all that kind of the symbolism of the
edge that we talked about in our
ethiopia videos so that's kind of like
the three canonical sons of noah if you
want to say that but then here in the
syrian account we have this idea of the
fourth son
yonatos or yonton who symbolizes the far
east and he lives in the land of the
dawn
and and the interesting thing is that he
has you could say the most access to
light he lives in the land where the sun
rises he is able
um
to learn astronomy like real astronomy
the gift of wisdom all these things but
he's not able to build a city for
himself yeah right so he's not able to
like embody himself in the world so it
takes the involvement of these other
sons of noah
and this story is probably uh you could
say in this the apocalypse of
pseudomethodius this is a reference to
another work called the cave of
treasures a very very important
syriac work
that it was historically attributed to
saint from the syrian
um and it's one of the main sources uh
basically the whole thing is you could
say it's like an extended midrash on
genesis so if you want to know like
early syrian christian understandings of
things like the watchers and the
descendants of seth still living on the
slopes of the mountain the lower slopes
of the mountain of paradise whereas the
descendants of canaan live down in the
valley and then cain's lineage they're
taught by demons and they invent musical
instrumentation so they can make this
noise and make these sounds and actually
attract and seduce the sons of seth down
yeah it's a whole i mean it's the whole
thing um
uh pretty pretty important to to like
you know doubt you know
that understanding of the world we've
talked about this but that understanding
of the world and i think specifically
the syrian expression of it is down at
the roots of pretty much all attempts to
to write universal history in the middle
ages yeah i think it's a really
important word
so if you think about it in terms of
yonatos and the idea of the east i mean
it can help us understand the east in
its in its symbolism as the source of
light and so that's why yonatos in this
case
in the positive sense is the place of
wisdom the place of
you know he he has this secret knowledge
this knowledge of the patterns that's
what astronomy is he kind of understands
the pattern but like you said he needs
support from the west to give him body
basically so you have a basic image of
the kind of the spiritual influence
coming from the east and then the west
capable of producing body so but it's
important for people to understand that
because when you when you read it it
might sound a little silly it might
sound a little ridiculous but you have
to understand that most people still
think that way now most people
even non-christian there's a weird
perversion of that which is you know go
to india find a guru go to go find some
buddhist master go so like this wisdom
from the east that comes you know and we
are these like horrible technical people
that are that that make machines but
have lost their spiritual connection so
the manner in which this is presented in
these very ancient texts finds a
corollary in
the way some new ager will think about
the world today
yeah so the danger here um is actually
also in this story uh because in this
version of the story in the cave of
treasures there is this guy a priest
named uh edisheer or artist here and uh
he sees that nimrod goes to the east and
all the stuff and he sees that yonatos
has this wisdom this true wisdom of
astronomy that he's gotten from god
right
and uh but it says the artist here is a
priest who ministers
to the fire that ascends from the earth
so you know this the idea there's
another source of light but the source
of light is
is uh it's like an artificial sunrise
you could say like as this fire that
comes up out of the earth
and there is a devil that appears to him
in connection with the fire and so in
this story
um he asked that devil to teach him the
wisdom that jonah's host has
and so the devil that appears in
connection with the fire that comes out
of the earth and obviously this is a
reference to
uh i mean this guy is the the guy who
found the magi so he this is a reference
it's talking about zoroastrianism
um
basically says okay well if you want to
do that there are these carnal rituals
you have like these incestuous rituals
that you have to partake in and if you
do that then i'll give you the wisdom
that you want so this idea of
participating in these carnal rituals
you get the wisdom that you're looking
for but the wisdom that he gets isn't
the true knowledge uh like the true
astrology or the truest astronomy that
yonatos has and the idea by the way is
that that that true astrology or that
true astronomy that's how the magi knew
that christ was being born right because
because they had access maybe you know
in the middle ages people believe that
that the magi had access through daniel
to like the real the real wisdom
but that this guy is the founder of the
zoroastrian magi and he gets this
knowledge from a devil from a demon
um
and that's the
that's the introduction of divination
magic which is the main kind of magic
for instance in the bible when it's
talking like all these things about
witches and wizards and things like this
it's not talking about people who are
like uh playing the environment and they
cast fireball right you know that's it's
talking about it's usually talking
specifically about divination magic and
also like curses things like that
um
lord spirits just did a great episode
about cursing and how that works and
stuff like that but um so there's this
idea that there is a uh
there's a real pattern but then there's
a danger like a false
you know a false riff or a false
rendition of that pattern and the danger
would be
going east
and
uh finding um not actually the true
wisdom that is from above but this this
false wisdom that actually comes from
below yeah and it's kind of instrumental
and
used and you can see that right in the
basic narrative of the book of enoch you
get a similar image of it or it's more
spiritualized we have the sense that
enoch there are these secret patterns
and there are these all these secret
patterns of reality and that the angels
are the watchers over these patterns but
if they are
let's say like the children of seth and
the
the children of uh of cain if they come
together in seduction and a desire for
power or desire to to make yourself more
powerful then they become a counterfeit
version of those patterns yeah so
you could say the in the in the syrian
literature which is really foundational
to the whole idea of a of a universal
history the far east is a place
from which
a genuine knowledge of that which is
higher can come
right but uh and even to the point of
pointing you to the coming of the
messiah into the world but that there is
you could say like an intermediate power
um in this case zoroastrianism but uh
you could you could substitute anything
else in that particular part of the
world right one of the things that we're
going to see that comes up constantly is
like there's something in the in the far
east and then there's suffering at
jerusalem and then whatever is in the
middle is always a problem right that's
going to be one of the general patterns
so eventually it's going to be in the
far east you have presser john
uh but in the middle you have the muslim
caliphates and then you have jerusalem
right here and the crusaders and all
that
yeah and there's a cosmic like again
there's a cosmic version of that which
is really exactly this idea the powers
of the air of the right exactly beings
you know the yeah skins or whatever all
these kind of intermediary intermit this
intermediary space
is a space which is important which has
a function and to kind of embody these
higher things into things we can deal
with but that's where all the danger is
because that's where pride is that's
where desire kind of finds its it's it's
glimmer yeah and there's another
important idea that i think also comes
to the fore here especially in uh the
the apocalypse of pseudomethodius
is this idea of
someone going from
rome in other words japheth you know
europe
um
uh medieval writers believe that japheth
was that the word jove like the name
jove jupiter was like a corruption of
japheth interesting um
uh you can agree with that or disagree
with that but that's what that's what
when people were writing medieval
history they they they saw jupiter as
being
this you know like a real historical
figure one of the sons of noah the
founder of europe who is then sort of
remembered and worshipped as a deity and
then maybe some demon comes in and
starts appropriating that worship at
some point but that that's how they saw
that so you see uh you see rome or
japheth
going to the far east to to to yonatos
as a craftsman
in order to build a city or to give body
to this pure logos of the east and this
turns out to be
the premise of a really important early
christian
slash gnostic work called the acts of
thomas
and it is a gnostic text i don't so i'm
not recommending people go out and read
it um there's a bunch of weird stuff in
there about you know how married people
shouldn't procreate even for the
purposes of procreation and stuff like
this
um that's certainly not what the church
teaches but this is a really early work
um and there are versions of it that
became very popular in the middle ages
and uh but for our purposes purposes the
ver the part of that story which is
important
is that it has thomas going to india to
evangelize but the way that he
evangelizes you know he's talking to
christ and christ is like and christ is
like go into the east
um and in this story um
uh there's a there's a legend that you
probably know
that uh thomas was like
christ's doppelganger yeah it was his
twin yeah and and in fact this is even
kind of like maybe
hinted at in the gospels right thomas
isn't hiding because he's afraid people
are going to mistake him for jesus and
and kill him you know
um
uh so this story is that that is kind of
in this story but um
basically he's talking to christ in
christ like i want you to india and
convert them and he says well how am i
going to get there you know and so
jesus says it's quite simple and so
jesus takes him down to the docks and
sells him into slavery
and he sells him as thomas like like
christ thomas is a carpenter he's a
skilled workman
and so christ sells him into slavery to
this indian traitor and that's how he
gets to
uh that's how he gets to the far east is
as a
as a as a carpenter and this brings him
to the far east and then we get this
idea of like going into the east and
building a city for the king of the east
this this story actually gets inverted a
little bit because what happens this is
the story of the conversion of king
gandafaris who is uh a historical figure
um who converted to christianity and the
story of his conversion is that thomas
shows up
and thomas is a very skilled carpenter
and so the king puts him in charge of
building him a new palace he gives him a
whole bunch of money goes away
and every so often uh he writes thomas
and says hey thomas how's the palace
going going and thomas says oh it's
going great you know uh the walls are up
i just need more money to finish the
roof so he sends more money oh the
roof's on i just need more money to
finish off the trim work all this stuff
so the king keeps sending more money
more money more money finally the king
comes back and there's no palace and he
goes to his guys and he's like what is
going on where's the palace that tom is
supposed to be building and they're all
like yeah that thomas guy he's just been
walking around giving all your money
away for
that's right
and uh so he's very upset and you know
he's going to punish thomas for this
but then the king's brother um
gad dies and goes to paradise and the
angels are showing him around
and they show him and he sees this
amazing palace and he says i'd like to
live there and they say oh well that
that should be just fine uh thomas has
been building that for your brother i'm
sure your brother wouldn't mind and so
gad comes back to life after the prayers
of saint thomas and tells gandalfari's
what he's seen and gandafaris and god
they both are baptized they become
christians and so on um and of course
there's a whole lineage of ancient
apostolic christianity still in the
indian subcontinent today which was
founded by the apostle thomas um there's
a bunch of different groups and it's
kind of loosely usually called saint
thomas christianity
um
so you i just point that out to say uh
the acts of thomas very important work
in in in the roman and christian world
understanding the far east
but also a very uh and and like the
whole idea of the naked philosopher and
all that stuff is in there too yeah but
it actually takes this
ancient sort of syrian idea
of
going to the east to build the city for
the king of the east but it it makes it
a heavenly city yeah
but then really i wanted to point out
one story from the legends of alexander
show about what the east could mean in
terms of it's it's also like a weird
inversion of that which is one of the
stories is that alexander comes and
meets the the philosophers and they're
naked they have nothing they have no
possession right then so alexander wants
to give them something so he gives them
this like precious oil or whatever and
of course the naked philosopher just
pours it out as a libation
because they can't own anything they are
they represent this lack of absence of
body right they're almost like
these crazy stories we hear of the naked
of the naked ascetics up on mount athos
right now that we're hearing from father
stephen and father andrew you know that
there that there are these are patterns
of uh these are patterns that kind of
reproduce themselves and yeah help us
understand what
what is the relationship between
let's say the higher aspect is this and
and how body interacts with it anyway so
that's something for all of you to think
about that we we still have a tradition
of naked aesthetics on marathons right
yeah
um yeah so all of this is like a nice
setup um for the thing that we really
want to talk about next um because
there's this
you could say this idea of the king in
the east
right um that this becomes one of the
most important ideas about understanding
the east when we get into the middle
ages
um
uh the so there are all these early
stories of of these righteous
pre-christian and christian kings in the
far east
um
the acts of thomas being a really good
example
that are the fountainhead for what
eventually becomes the medieval legend
of prester john right professor john
meaning john the priest presser means
priest the idea presser john is that
he's a priest king he's uh he's he's a
king of the east who is also a christian
priest and is able to offer the
eucharist he's a man he's a melchizedek
figure yeah a melchizedek kind of a
figure
and um
and this idea i mean when
this this idea that arises in the 12th
century 13th century that uh this there
would be a christian king out of these
who would actually uh attack the arab
caliphate liberate jerusalem
and uh sort of save the christian people
in the in in the middle east
from their oppressors
and um so those are kind of
uh let's say that's the groundwork those
are the big patterns
and that's what starts to manifest in
the legends of professor john
all right and so
we have so i think we've got the basic
structure we understand that for the
medieval christians jerusalem is at the
middle it's like the heart of the world
and then you have the east which has two
aspects of it two extremes which could
be something like the two aspects some
of the aspects of what
uh hierarchy offers you know this order
this light which comes from above but
then also the possibility of a kind of
excess
uh
of this idea of luxury and of excess of
degeneracy which also is represented as
coming from the east there is the
relation there's also the notion that
there's this intermediary space which
appears in our cosmic vision of the
world itself which is that we have the
highest point of light above and then we
have all these intermediary beings in
between and those intermediary beings
are possibly ambiguous they could go
they said they're good ones and they're
bad ones so you have that sense as well
in this so you can understand how the
way in which the
medievals understood the map itself and
their
the way they embodied space
was something which was based on their
own kind of cosmic vision yeah and will
strangely
manifest itself that way as well as we
continue on the story maybe a nice coda
to leave people on if people want to go
do a little homework for next video
um
go google something called the voyages
of
[Music]
bar salma s-a-u-m-a the voyages of rabon
salma do you know about this no
so
this is this uh i mentioned this earlier
to you we were planning but oh this is
the this is the punk
yeah so there's a monk from peking in
china so this is all the way in
northeastern china almost
you know like uh
almost in korea at this point okay it's
how far east this guy is he is a we're
going to be talking a lot next time
about
what is sometimes called the nestorian
church or the church of the east
um so he's a monk and a bishop in this
church
and he is asked by his bishop at the
time to undertake a
journey to
jerusalem to the holy land
to undertake a pilgrimage
and so he begins this journey
all the way from uh peaking in in uh or
what we now call beijing sorry i know
that's
uh
all my old books sometimes get in the
way yeah you guys know what i'm talking
about so it goes all the way from
beijing in china
uh makes it to baghdad makes it to
constantinople he makes it to rome he
makes it to paris
he meets uh he makes it all the way to
uh gascony what is now called bordeaux
france where he meets edward the first
the king of england and also part of
france at the time
and uh actually serves liturgy and
communes edward the first at the liturgy
um before heading back um he
he stops in rome we're going to talk
more about this next video but he stops
in rome he has arguments with the roman
cardinals about the filioque
um which which he all he writes about in
his own first in his own words
um and then eventually makes it back to
baghdad where he dies in 1294
um so the great thing about this travel
account
is that it's sort of it's roughly
contemporary with marco polo a little
bit earlier i think but he is uh
it's it's a first-hand eyewitness
account not of the strange experience of
going west to east
but rather the experience of going east
to west
and the thing is if you take a look at
his account what you will see is that
even though he's from beijing
even though he's traveling the complete
opposite direction as most of the travel
logs that we think about when we think
about this
his world
is also centered on jerusalem
and
what you will read is even though it
seems like he should belong to a
different world with a different
perspective because he also has this
jerusalem-centric point of view
as he travels
his his his
account is a christian account of the
world
when he goes to constantinople when he
goes to rome when he goes to all these
different places what does he want to do
he wants to go see the churches
and he has this beautiful description
for instance of aguero sophia
and the relics that he was able to
venerate while he was there he wants to
see the churches and he wants to see the
relics that they keep in those churches
and these these are the most important
things to him
so
um i think that uh this account really
goes a long way and unfortunately it's
not well known and i encourage people to
go out and read it uh you can find the
whole thing online uh in in translation
for free
but this account is
uh a very important witness to the
things that we're talking about not just
being
eurocentric not just being
like an american idea or something like
this but as being truly universal right
they're universal
because they are first specific right
um and the unit it's it's a universal
way of understanding the world because
it's a way of understanding the world
that is oriented towards jerusalem
yeah all right everybody so uh next next
episode a lot of crazy stuff muggles
spread through john we're gonna get into
the real juicy stuff oh it's gonna it's
gonna be really fun gonna get bloody
also also very bloody it's gonna be very
bloody right yeah all right everybody
thanks for your attention and uh we'll
talk to you very soon
bye
this episode is part of a series of
discussions i've had with richard roland
on universal history you can find a list
of all these episodes on my youtube
channel where you can find them also in
my podcast stream from the symbolic
world on your different podcast
platforms make sure to check out
richard's second podcast which he hosts
in collaboration with father andrew
damick called ammunsuol which looks at
the relationship between tolkien and
orthodoxy this podcast has also inspired
me some ideas for creating some images
whether it be the king under the
mountain whether it be the grail or
beautiful ethiopian traditions i've
created some products which you can find
on my store the symbolicworld.store
and there will probably be more of those
to come very soon so stay tuned this
conversation is ongoing and there is
still very much to explore in the
universal history